Ihr Journalisten
bringt es nicht fertig,
den "Gefängniswärter"
aus eurem Vokabular zu löschen.
Beim "Tierpfleger"
habt ihr's geschafft:
Den Tierwärter gibt's nicht mehr.
Aussenstehende sagen oft:
"Dieser Gefängniswärter-Mist da."
Für die bin ich der Schlüsselknecht
mit dem Schlüsselbund. Was soll's?
Das ist etwas,
was ich die ganzen 40 Jahre
immer wieder verdrängen musste.
Die haben keine Ahnung, was wir tun,
und im Speziellen keine Ahnung,
was ich getan habe.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Unüberhörbar.
Dieser Mann trägt sein Herz
auf der Zunge: Christian Harder.
Seit 38 Jahren ist er Mitarbeiter
der Justizvollzugsanstalt Lenzburg.
Ich begleite ihn
während seiner letzten Monate im
Berufsalltag bis zur Pensionierung.
Kennengelernt habe ich
Christian Harder vor einem Jahr
bei Dreharbeiten über Sicherheits-
massnahmen im Strafvollzug.
Ein sturer Hardliner, ein Sheriff
aus dem Aargau halt, dachte ich.
Weit gefehlt: Hinter der harten Scha-
le versteckt sich ein weicher Kern.
Die Drohne ist ungefährlich.
Ihr könnt sie holen kommen.
Manchmal widersprüchlich,
aber immer herzlich.
So erlebte ich Christian Harder.
Lenzburg:
zwei Gefängnisse, eine Anstalt.
Die Strafanstalt und
das 300 m entfernte Zentralgefängnis.
In beiden sorgt Christian Harder
für die Sicherheit.
Im Moment
ärgern ihn die Laserscanner,
welche die Mauer überwachen.
Weil die Mauer oben flach ist,
war sie Tummelplatz für die Krähen.
Krähen mit voller Flügelspannbreite
wurden detektiert.
D.h., die Laserscanner reagierten
und lösten einen Alarm aus.
Zu viele Fehlalarme im Kontrollraum,
so Harder,
sind der Tod für die Sicherheit.
Also hat er den Überwachungsstreifen
ein wenig nach unten verschoben.
Nun testet er die neue Einstellung.
Sehr pragmatisch,
so wie ich ihn immer erlebte.
Dies ist einer seiner letzten Jobs,
Ende Woche geht er nämlich in Rente.
Alarm Peripherie Nord, Haus B.
Es funktioniert.
Ausbrecher und Einbrecher haben heute
bei ihm praktisch keine Chance mehr.
Das war früher anders.
Wir haben nie irgendwo
präventiv etwas verbessert.
Wenn man das Gefühl hatte:
"Hier haben wir noch eine Lücke",
wartete man ab, bis etwas passierte.
Nach dem Ereignis mussten wir
handeln und handelten auch.
Ist das nicht fahrlässig?
Das hat sich alles entwickelt.
Das alte Gefängnis
hatte nur kleine Mauern.
Man wusste,
dass ein Flucht möglich war.
Der Fünfstern von Lenzburg:
mehr als 150-jährig.
Die Mauern waren nur 4 m hoch
und die Gitterstäbe an den Fenstern
noch weich,
als Christian Harder 1981 hier
als einfacher Vollzugsbeamter
angestellt wurde.
Im Vergleich zu heute
seien sie damals
ein verschworenes Team gewesen.
Daneben haben sich aber
die Arbeit und der Vollzug
eindeutig zum Positiven verändert.
Sonst wäre er
gar nicht so lange geblieben,
betont er mir gegenüber mehrfach.
Eintritte, Austritte,
aber auch Fluchten wurden noch fein
säuberlich von Hand protokolliert,
bis der Technikfreak Harder
den ersten Computer brachte.
1989 überredete er
den damaligen Direktor
zu den ersten Überwachungskameras,
und dies gegen den ausdrücklichen
Willen von einigen älteren Kollegen.
Über 7 m hoch ist heute die Mauer.
Zudem wird sie mehrfach
elektronisch überwacht.
Die Strafanstalt verfügt u.a. über
ein Programm zum Erkennen von Handys
und ein Abwehrsystem für Drohnen.
Er braucht es mir gar nicht zu sagen,
dass er alles mit initiiert hat.
Das ist eine der schönsten
Anstalten, die es noch gibt -
architektonisch.
Und sie ist v.a. gepflegt.
Aber vollgepumpt
mit modernster Technik.
24 Std. pro Tag
wird jeder Schrank und jede Tür
in dieser Leitzentrale überwacht,
denn hier laufen
alle Systeme zusammen.
Ich staune über seine Fachkenntnisse.
Ich bin natürlich stolz darauf,
dass ein Grossteil
der eingesetzten Sicherheitstechnik
heute funktioniert und -
das ist das Wichtigste -
die Gefangenen davon profitieren.
Mein Nachfolger
ist von Haus aus Informatiker.
Ich musste all dies lernen.
Ich konnte das nicht, aber
ich war fasziniert von dem Zeug.
Gleich daneben, auch im Untergrund,
in einer ehemaligen Arrestzelle,
hütet Harder einen weiteren Schatz.
Hier haben wir ein kleines Museum
eingerichtet mit Risikogegenständen,
aber auch mit Gegenständen, die
zur Fluchthilfe benutzt worden sind.
Das beginnt mit kleinen Eisensägen,
denn die alten Gitter konnte man
sogar mit einem guten,
gezackten Brotmesser durchsägen.
Nachher sahen die Gitterstäbe
dann so aus:
auf der einen Seite angerostet, auf
der anderen ein sauberer Schnitt.
Zwei solche Stäbe weg, dann
passte ein Mensch durchs Gitter.
Zu den klassischen
Überstiegswerkzeugen:
z.B. gestohlene Metallteile
aus der Schlosserei,
die irgendwann
zusammengebastelt wurden,
bis daraus eine Leiter entstand.
Alles aus Zeiten
der alten Peripherie.
Oder es wurden aus Stoffresten
Seile geknüpft.
Z.T. finden sich hier
sehr schöne Sachen,
z.T. auch Sachen,
über die man lachen muss.
Das ist ein schöner Gegenstand,
mit dem eine Flucht gelungen ist:
dank dieser Strickleiter.
Diese Metallschienen
stammen aus der Schlosserei,
damit hatten sie gearbeitet.
Stück für Stück hatten sie für
diesen Zweck verschwinden lassen.
Alles noch aus den Zeiten, als wir
noch keine Metalldetektoren hatten.
Vor gelungenen Fluchten
hatte ich immer Respekt.
Nur wenige Wochen
nach meinem Arbeitsbeginn hier
kletterte ich erstmals
über die alte Mauer,
um zu sehen, was es braucht:
Das ist eine Leistung.
In meiner Brust
schlugen schon immer zwei Herzen.
Fluchten sind sicher zu verhindern,
aber wenn es einer
raffiniert geschafft hat:
Chapeau! Das ist so.
Ebenfalls im Museum:
Wurfsterne, Messer, Schlagringe.
Alles Gegenstände,
welche bei Gefangenen
entdeckt und konfisziert wurden.
Darunter sogar
eine selbstgebaute Schusswaffe
und eine einfache Schnapsbrennerei.
Das Schlimmste hier drin
war der Alkohol.
Der ist irgendwie verschwunden.
Das hat damit zu tun, dass keine
Insassen mehr draussen arbeiten.
Der Schmuggel von Alkohol ist viel
komplizierter als der von Cannabis.
Mit anderen Worten:
Heute wird mehr gekifft als gesoffen.
Und das ist besser für euch.
Das kann man so sagen:
Es ist weniger schlimm.
Ein Kiffer wird
nicht aggressiv wie ein Alkoholiker.
Für uns ist das
sicher weniger schlimm,
aber letztlich dasselbe:
Es ist hier drin verboten.
Wir müssen es bekämpfen,
und das tun wir auch.
Hier haben wir noch ein Utensil,
mit dem tatsächlich
ein Angriff auf einen Angestellten
stattgefunden hatte.
Er kriegte diese Pfanne an den Kopf.
Gesundheitlich
trug er keinen Schaden davon.
Das ist mind. 30 Jahre her.
Zurück in die Gegenwart.
Harder
präsentiert sein allerletztes Baby.
Die neue Videoüberwachung.
120 Kameras dokumentieren das Innen-
und Aussenleben der Strafanstalt.
Bis zu einer Woche können
die Aufnahmen gespeichert werden.
Harder betreut die Sicherheitssysteme
nicht nur,
er bildet auch
die Mitarbeiter darin aus.
Mit dem 30-fachen Zoom lassen sich
sogar kleine Kieselsteine ausspähen.
Physische Kontrollgänge
werden so fast überflüssig.
Im Sicherheitsdienst haben wir
tatsächlich Stellen eingespart
aufgrund der Technik,
die wir jetzt hier haben.
Aber die Hauptwirkung all
dieser Technik, dieser Sicherheit -
angefangen bei der Mauer
bis zur Überwachung ...
Den Hauptvorteil davon
haben die Gefangenen,
weil wir mit dem Tagesablauf
hier drin
viel lockerer umgehen können
als vorher.
Die Gefangen können sich heute
innerhalb des Areals
relativ frei bewegen -
sei es bei der Arbeit
oder in der Freizeit.
Dennoch: Insgesamt 15 Std. täglich
müssen sie sich
in den Zellen aufhalten.
Ein weiterer Vorteil
für die Insassen:
Dank der fast lückenlosen Überwachung
lassen sich Übergriffe
schneller erkennen und beurteilen.
Das hat eine präventive Wirkung.
Christian Harder ist sichtlich stolz
auf all diese
technischen Errungenschaften.
Diese Anstalt
war 38 Jahre lang mein Leben.
Dazu stehe ich:
Ich bin eine aussterbende Rasse.
Aber es ist jetzt auch gut.
Bei dieser Entwicklung,
dieser Dynamik hier
komme ich auch nicht mehr mit.
Dafür musste ich jetzt
noch einmal alles geben.
Jetzt kommt eine neue Generation,
die damit aufgewachsen ist.
Und wenn ihm alles zu viel wird,
dann hat er noch sein Boot.
Seit 15 Jahren findet er
mit seiner Lebenspartnerin
Erholung auf dem Wasser.
Aktuell schippert er
über den Neuenburgersee.
Hier erlebe ich ihn zum ersten Mal
so richtig nachdenklich,
fast schon melancholisch.
Ich wurde bei meiner Arbeit
im Strafvollzug verhärtet.
Ich kann nicht mehr
über jeden Mist lachen.
Das ist mir abhandengekommen.
Ich bin etwas ernster geworden,
weil ich vieles gesehen habe,
das nicht in Ordnung ist,
das falsch bewertet wird.
Wenn ich an die Sache
mit der Verwahrung denke,
dann muss ich einfach sagen:
"Was denkt ein Volk,
das eine solche Vorlage annimmt?"
Oder:
"Wie wurde das Volk irregeführt,
dass es diese Vorlage
angenommen hatte?"
20-Jährige lebenslänglich zu
verwahren, womöglich noch Ersttäter.
Jetzt muss ich wieder aufpassen,
dass ich sie nicht in Schutz nehme.
So politisch solche Aussagen sind,
auf eine Richtung
lässt er sich nicht festlegen.
Er habe,
auch das betonte er immer wieder,
kein Mitleid mit den Gefangenen.
Sein Auftrag sei aber,
diese Menschen würdig zu betreuen.
Dass ihm dies gelingt,
habe ich mehrfach erlebt.
Wenn ich miterleben musste,
dass z.B. ein Gefangener
von seiner Zelle bis zum Pavillon,
du kennst die Distanzverhältnisse,
diese 30 m, 5-7 Min. gebraucht hat -
aufgrund seines Alters
und seines Gesundheitszustandes.
Und trotzdem gilt er weiterhin
als extrem gefährlich.
Er darf nicht in ein Sterbehospiz.
Das sei zu gefährlich.
Da greife ich mir an den Kopf.
Gleichzeitig befürchtet er,
dass in Zukunft der Staat
aus Angst vor der Justiz
die Gefangenen noch mehr schütze
als den einfachen Bürger.
Nun, allzu lange muss ihn das
ja nicht mehr kümmern,
denn seine Zukunft
ist ausserhalb des Gefängnisses.
Ich kann noch nicht recht glauben,
dass irgendwann wirklich
der letzte Tag sein wird.
Angst ist das falsche Wort,
aber ich bin sehr gespannt,
was mit mir passieren wird,
wenn plötzlich ein wesentlicher Teil
des Lebens wegbricht.
Noch aber dominiert der Strafvollzug.
An seinem ersten Arbeitstag
drückte man ihm
einfach eine Pistole in die Hand.
Tempi passati.
Bis in die frühen 2000er-Jahre
trugen wir Schusswaffen.
Wir hatten nie ein Training,
wie es z.B. die Polizei hat.
Es gab einen Zwischenfall
mit einer Schusswaffe.
Sie fiel zu Boden,
und ein Schuss löste sich.
Ich machte mich persönlich bei
der damaligen Leitung dafür stark,
dass man damit aufhört.
Aber wir brauchen ein Instrument,
um uns in einem absoluten Notfall
verteidigen zu können.
Dieses Instrument ist der Taser.
In Lenzburg
kam er erst einmal zum Einsatz.
Umso wichtiger ist die
regelmässige Ausbildung an dem Gerät.
Diese Elektroimpulswaffe
macht eine getroffene Person
für einen Moment immobil.
Einschalten.
Sie verfügt über einen Laserpointer.
Das Display ist sehr wichtig,
um zu überprüfen,
ob sie geladen ist:
Sind zwei 25er geladen und nicht
zwei Manipulationskartuschen,
die gar nicht funktionieren?
Kann bei uns nicht passieren,
aber gehört zur Ausbildung.
Und dann
ist das Gerät einsatzbereit.
Du siehst, wie die Zeit abläuft,
und fertig.
Als die Taser aufkamen,
waren sie so umstritten,
dass man sagte: "Der Anwender
muss wissen, was er tut."
Es wurde die Selbsterfahrung
empfohlen, wie man das nannte.
Auch Harder
musste so einen Selbstversuch
über sich ergehen lassen.
Das waren
die längsten 5 Sek. in meinem Leben.
Das war einfach nur grausam.
Wie fühlt man sich
nach diesen 5 Sek.?
Genau wie vorher.
Ich war einfach froh,
dass es vorbei war.
Aber physisch und psychisch hatte
ich gar nichts verspürt, gar nichts.
Die zwei Pfeile im Körper
waren kein Problem mehr.
Der grössere Schmerz
vertreibt immer den kleineren.
Vom Taser und der Sicherheitstechnik
zurück in die Zeit,
als eine Strafanstalt
noch wirklich der Strafe
und nicht der Resozialisierung
diente.
Christian Harder zeigt uns
die einzige noch vorhandene,
ursprüngliche Zelle.
Schau dir diese Zelle an.
Heute würde diese Tür
nach einer Woche aufgebrochen.
Das ist ein Spiegelbild
der damaligen Gesellschaft.
Draussen
hatte man es auch nicht viel besser.
Man lebte sehr einfach.
Der Teller auf dem Tisch war karg.
Auch der heutige Vollzug
ist ein Spiegelbild:
ein Flachbildschirm in der Zelle.
Logisch, sonst kann man gar nicht
leben, wenn man nichts mehr weiss.
Es gibt hier
sonst schon genug Einschränkungen.
Da ist er wieder, der
verständnisvolle Vollzugsmitarbeiter.
Er glaubt an die positive Entwicklung
der meisten Insassen.
Deshalb würde er ja auch die
lebenslange Verwahrung abschaffen.
Das würde ich als Erstes tun.
Ich würde versuchen, in der Gesell-
schaft die Meinung zu korrigieren,
dass es
keine absolute Sicherheit gibt.
Und drittens
brauchen wir Schuldige für alles.
Wer ist schuld,
wenn einer rückfällig wird?
Der Psychiater, der sagte:
"Probieren wir es"?
Nein, der Rückfällige ist schuld.
Wer ist schuld, dass in Deutschland
einer mit dem Lastwagen
in den Weihnachtsmarkt gefahren ist?
Frau Merkel?
Der Lastwagenfahrer ist schuld.
Ende der Durchsage.
Harder ist ein vehementer Verfechter
einer echten Resozialisierung.
Dazu gehört für ihn
das Training von Körper und Geist.
Ich denke,
es war Anfang der 90er-Jahre,
als die Fitnesswelle -
auch in den Knästen -
aus Amerika
zu uns herüberschwappte.
Ich legte
die nötigen Zeitungsausschnitte
den richtigen Leuten
auf den Bürotisch.
Irgendwann
bekam ich einen Raum zur Verfügung
und 18'000 Fr.
für Geräte und Ausrüstung.
Dann hatten wir unser erstes Studio.
Anfangs hiess es:
"Spinnst du eigentlich?"
"Was willst du denen
noch Muskeln antrainieren?"
Das war nicht ganz einfach.
In diesem Fitnessraum
steckt kein einziger Steuerfranken.
Das ist ihm ganz wichtig.
Jetzt gehst du weiter runter, los.
Einmal pro Woche dürfen die Insassen
in den Kraftraum.
Christian Harder
unterstützt sie bei ihrem Training.
Ich spüre sein Engagement für diesen
Sport, aber auch für die Insassen.
Er ist
ein sehr sympathischer, cooler Typ.
Er ist immer hilfsbereit,
wenn ich Fragen zum Training habe.
Er achtet darauf, dass die Übungen
korrekt ausgeführt werden,
ist immer für uns da.
Das ist ein Mosaik: Ich lege ein
Teilchen, der Sozialdienst eines,
die Mitgefangenen eines -
alle tragen ein Teilchen bei.
Und vielleicht funktioniert es -
und vielleicht auch nicht.
Noch heute kritisieren Aussenstehende
und Besucher das tolle Studio:
Das sei ein übertriebener Luxus.
Die Täter würden verwöhnt
statt bestraft.
Harder kennt diese Argumente -
zu Genüge.
Wie sollen sie sein, wenn sie
die Strafe abgesessen haben?
Vollgefressen, dick, arbeitsunfähig?
Verblödet, aggressiv?
Wie sollen wir sie entlassen?
Sollen wir es wie in Amerika machen?
Dort bekommen sie 250 Jahre Knast,
50 Jahre davon werden erlassen.
Dann muss man nichts mehr tun.
Das ist nicht das Ziel
unseres Strafvollzugs.
Unser Ziel ist,
die Jungs wieder brauchen zu können.
Vor 30 Jahren erhielt er
von einem professionellen Bodybuilder
einen Trainings- und Ernährungsplan.
Ich lernte,
morgens um 6 Uhr Spaghetti zu essen.
Nachdem er mich ein Jahr lang
beobachtet hatte, sagte er:
"Jetzt bist du 36. Mit 40 wirst du
Schweizer Meister - wenn du willst."
Da antwortete ich: "Hallo?"
Und dann habe ich
diese Ernährungs- und Trainingspläne
voll durchgezogen -
und es hat funktioniert.
Auf Anhieb wurde er Schweizer Meister
bei den über 40-Jährigen.
Ich bin 65 und kann mich hier
noch immer zeigen.
Hier geniesse ich
allerhöchsten Respekt, noch immer.
Oft wird das Foto von mir
als 40-Jähriger herumgereicht.
Das wollen sie immer wieder sehen.
Sie reden von Vorbildern.
Das ist doch schön, oder.
Für mich ist es
nicht nur das Bodybuilding.
Ich habe den ganzen Tag
mit ihnen zu tun.
Ich habe es gut hier drin.
Ich habe es gut mit den Gefangenen,
und sie haben es gut mit mir,
sonst hätte ich das
nicht so lange gemacht.
Diese Jungs werden mir fehlen.
Wohl deshalb wird er
auch nach der Pensionierung
noch einen Abend pro Woche
in "seinem" Studio verbringen.
Dann aber ist es endgültig so weit:
Harders letzter Arbeitstag
in seinem Fünfstern.
Ein letztes Mal
durch den Irisscanner.
Die Identifizierung ist beendet.
Dann folgt die Ehrenrunde.
Ich bin froh, dass ich gehen kann,
aber es ist auch Wehmut mit dabei.
Da steckt mein Herzblut drin.
Diese Anstalt bedeutet mir etwas.
Also Jungs, macht's gut.
Trag Sorge zu dir.
Tschau René, tschau Renzo.
- Bleib gesund.
* Er summt vor sich hin. *
Ab und zu werde ich
noch zum Bodybuilding kommen.
Im Oktober und November habe ich
bereits vier Freitage eingetragen.
Also, macht's gut.
Ich habe es gesehen.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Husas, bau keinen Mist.
Wirst du Velo fahren gehen?
- Ich werde alles machen:
Holz hacken, Gärtnern, mit
dem Schiff fahren - und nichts tun.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Vor dem offiziellen Abschiedsessen
gibt's noch einen Apéro
mit der Geschäftsleitung.
Exklusiv der Ort:
heute Weinkeller, früher Arrestzelle.
Und zum ersten Mal erlebe ich ihn
so richtig diplomatisch.
Ich möchte mich wirklich bedanken
für die 38 Jahre
voller toller Erlebnisse:
Ich hatte Ärger,
der sich immer wieder beruhigt hat.
Ich war immer motiviert.
Es war einfach nur super,
was wir seit 1982 bis heute
in dieser Anstalt machen durften.
Besten Dank
und euch alles Gute weiterhin.
Zum Wohl.
Mit Harder verschwinde
ein Original aus dem Strafvollzug,
meint sein Chef.
Wenn jemand von der Pike auf
ein Berufsumfeld kennengelernt hat,
von ganz unten bis ganz oben,
dann ist das durchaus
auch positiv für die Firma.
Das ist meine persönliche Meinung.
Ein Mitarbeiter
wie Christian Harder,
der sich in den 40 Jahren bei uns
so entwickelt hat,
der viele Innovationen
angerissen hat,
macht mich
als Direktor dieser Anstalt stolz.
Entlassung.
Für die meisten Insassen
der erste Schritt in die Freiheit.
Ob dies bei Christian Harder
auch der Fall ist?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Wer seinen Job
so leidenschaftlich erfüllte,
für den ist die Pensionierung
eine echte Herausforderung.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Roger Schmid - 2020